is there some elegant basic symbol that
you're attracted to some
uh
give something that gives you pleasure
something used a lot
pie
pie of course
uh i try to use pie
as often as i can when i need a random
example
because it doesn't have any uh
known characters so for
for instance
i i don't have here to show you but uh
do you do you know the
uh
the game called masu m-a-s-y-u
no it's it
it's a great
recreation i mean
sudoku is easier to understand but
matthew is it he is more addictive uh
uh
you you have black and white stones like
like on a go board
and you have to draw a path that
goes straight through a white stone and
makes a right angle turn at the black
stone
um and
it turns out to be really
really nice puzzle because it doesn't
involve numbers
but with this visual but it's
3d pleasant to to play with
so so i wanted to
use it as example in art of computer
programming and i have
um i have exercises on how to design
cool massive puzzles
and uh you can find that on wikipedia
certainly uh
as an example
m-a-s-y-u
um and and so i and so i decided i would
take pi
the actual
image of it and it
had pixels and i
would put a stone
wherever uh it belongs in the letter pi
in the greek letter
and and but
the problem was
find a way to make some of the stones
white some of the stones black so that
there's a unique solution to the
mossview puzzle
that was a good test case for my
algorithm on how to design master
puzzles because i
i insisted in advance
that the stones had to be placed in
exactly the positions that make the
letter pi make a juice letter okay
all right that's cool and and i saw you
know
and it turned out there was a a a unique
way to do that
um and so
so pi is a
source of
of examples where i can
where i can prove that i'm starting with
something that isn't canned yeah
and and most most recently i was writing
about something called graceful graphs
uh graceful graphs
is the following you have a graph that
has
uh m edges to it
all right and
you attach numbers to every vertex
in the following way so every time you
have an edge between vertices you take
the difference between those numbers
and and that difference is it's got to
be it can tell you what edge it is so so
one edge two numbers will be one apart
there'll be another edge where the
numbers are two apart and so a
great computer problem
can you find a graceful way to label a
graph
so i started with the
so i started with a graph that i use for
an organic graph not
not a
mathematically symmetric graph or
anything and i take this i take the 49
states of the united states
uh
the edges that go from one state to a
next state so for example california be
next to oregon
nevada
arizona okay
and and
and i include this district of columbia
uh so i have 49 i can't get at la alaska
and hawaii in there because they don't
touch you have to be able to drive from
one to the other so is there a graceful
labeling of of the united states
each state gets a number
and then if california is number 30 and
oregon is number 11
that edge is going to be number 19. the
difference between those right okay
so is there a way to do this for for all
the states
and
the end so i was i was thinking of
having a contest
uh
for people to to get it as graceful as
they could
uh but my friend tamar kiki
actually solved the problem by proving
that i mean i was able i was able to get
it down
within seven or something like that he
was able to get a perfect solution
the actual solution are to prove that a
solution exists
more precisely i i had figured out a way
to put labels on so that
all the all the
all the edges were labeled somewhere
between 1 and 117
but but there were some some get some
gaps in there because
i should really have gone from 1 to 105
or what the whatever the number is so
i gave myself a too much
you know a lot of slack okay so he did
it without any slack whatsoever a
perfect grace for labeling
and and so i you know i
call out the contest uh because the
problems already sounded too easy in a
sense because tom was able to do it in
an afternoon um
sorry he gave the algorithm or for this
particular uh for the stick united
states for the united states this
problem is
this problem is incredibly hard i mean
for the general generally okay
but it's like it's like coloring but it
was very lucky that would work for the
united states sure um i think but i mean
the theory is still very uncomplete but
but but anyway then tom came back a
couple days later and he had been able
to not only find a graceful labeling but
he
but
the label of washington was 31.
the label of
of idaho
was 41 following the digits of pi
yeah
going across the the topic of the united
states he has the digits of pipelines
did he do it on purpose
he was able to still get a graceful
labeling with that with
that extra thing
wow
it's a miracle okay but yeah but um i
uh
i like to use pie in my book you see and
this is the
all roads lead to pie yeah somehow um
somehow often hidden
uh in the middle of like the the most
difficult problems
can i ask you about uh
productivity
productivity yeah you said that quote my
scheduling principle
is to do the thing i hate most
uh on my to-do list
by week's end i'm very happy
can you explain this process to a
productive life
oh i see well
but all the time i'm working out and
what i want i what i don't want to do
but still i'm glad to have all those
unpleasant tasks finished yes is that
something you would advise to others
well i yeah i i i don't know how to say
it
during the pandemic i feel my
productivity actually went down by half
because i have to
um
i i have to communicate by
writing which is slow i have to
i mean i i don't like to send out a bad
sentence so i
you know i go through and reread what
i've written and edit and fix it so so
everything takes a long a lot longer
when i'm
when i'm communicating by
by text messages um
instead of just
you know on
together with somebody in a room and
it's also
slower because the libraries are closed
and stuff
but there's another thing about
scheduling that i learned from my mother
that i should probably tell you and that
is
um it's different from what the people
in the robotics field do
which is called planning
so she had this principle
that was
see something that needs to be done and
do it
you know just
instead of saying i'm going to do this
first and do this first
just
you know
just do it oh yeah pick this up you know
but you're at any one moment there's a
set of tasks that you can do and you're
saying a good heuristic
is to do the the one you want to do
least
right
the one i haven't got any good reason i
i think
that i'll never be
able to do it any better than i am now
i mean there are some things that that i
know
if i do
something else first then i'll be able
to do that one better yeah but but but
there's some that are going to be harder
because you know
i've forgotten some of the
groundwork that went into it or
something like that
so so i just finished uh
a pretty tough part of the book and uh
and so and so now i'm
you know doing the parts that are more
fun
but but but the other thing is as i'm
writing the book of course i want
the reader to think that i'm happy all
the time i'm writing the book
you know that it's upbeat i i can have
humor i can you know i can i can say
this is cool you know
wow
this uh i have to i have to disguise the
fact that
it was painful in any way
the road to that excitement is painful
yeah it's laden with pain
okay is is there um you've given some
advice to people before
but can you uh
can you you give me too too much credit
but anyway this is my this is my turn to
just not to say things that are that
that i believe but
but i want to preface it by saying uh
i also believe that
other people do a lot of these things
much better than i do so i can only tell
you
my side of it